kein positiver trend bei den
neuinfektionen experten warnen dass mehr
getan werden muss um die virus
mutationen zu stoppen
kein ende der haft ein moskauer gericht
hat die berufung des kreml kritikers
navalny abgelehnt und kein frost mehr
deutschland feiert den frühling im
februar sonne tanken gegen winter und
kronau frust
die nachrichten nicht erst heute mit
christian sievers ich begrüße sie alle
ganz herzlich guten abend sport in der
sendung nachher mit kristin otto voller
freude kund
zumindest das wetter heute deutet auf
ein ende des langen kalten winters hin
die krone lage in deutschland bleibt
allerdings schwierig der positive trend
scheint gebrochen und so sehen die
aktuellen corona zahlen aus das robert
koch institut meldet innerhalb eines
tages 9000 164 neuinfektionen das sind
810 mehr als vergangenen samstag 490
menschen starben in verbindung mit 19
die inzidenz stieg erstmals seit
längerem wieder und liegt jetzt bei 57,8
eine entwicklung die politik und
experten sorgen macht frank buchwald
wieder hat das virus zugeschlagen
diesmal in franken 40 infizierte in
einer klinik die inzidenz im landkreis
hof steigt auf über 200 corona noch
lange nicht besiegt die große hoffnung
impfen in berlin stellen sich minister
sparen und seine experten online den
fragen der bürger
[Musik]
frau gepflegt ihre 89 jährige mutter
eine zufriedenstellende antwort aber
kann der minister heute nicht geben es
wird echt schwierig sein das ist noch
eine herausforderung wo ich gerade mit
den ländern im gespräch bin wie wir das
eigentlich sozusagen nachvollziehbar
machen wer ist kontaktpersonen von wem
ich kann ihnen also noch nicht ganz
genau sagen wie wir dass wir das jetzt
in die umsetzung bringen wer wann
geimpft wird bleibt umstritten lehrer
und erzieherinnen aber könnten auf
rücken schlägt spahn vor zwar gingen die
infektionen leicht zurück zugleich aber
warnen virologen vor ansteckenden
varianten des virus
was wir aber auch sehen dass in den
letzten wochen die anzahl der
infektionen mit den varianten zugenommen
hat das heißt das was wir im moment
machen reicht nicht aus um eben auch
diese ausbreitung der varianten
dementsprechend in schach zu halten oder
eben reduzieren zu können
deshalb gilt weiterhin abstand halten
masken zu hause bleiben denn bis alle
die wollen auch geimpft sind werden
gewiss noch monate vergehen
die ausbeutung von mutationen des corona
virus bereitet derzeit auch in
schleswig-holstein sorgen
dort hat sich flensburg an der grenze zu
dänemark zu einem hotspot entwickelt die
sieben tage incidents liegt dort
mittlerweile bei 191 und es geht fast
nur noch um neuinfektionen mit der
britischen variante
deshalb gilt seit heute eine nächtliche
ausgangssperre private treffen sind ganz
verboten
dänemark hat mehrere grenzübergänge
geschlossen über den lock down in
flensburg so hat krall die korona
kontrolle auf dem wochenmarkt in
flensburg einkaufen ist hier nur noch
einzeln erlaubt seit mitternacht gelten
für die fördestadt noch einmal
verschärfte auflagen wer dagegen
verstößt muss mit einem bußgeld rechnen
verstöße gegen die ausgangs
beschränkungen kontakt geschenken das
sind in erster linie
ordnungswidrigkeiten die kann geahndet
werden mit bußgeldern von 100 euro bis
hin zu 25.000 euro
flensburg im lotto private treffen sind
untersagt von 21 bis 5 uhr gilt eine
nächtliche ausgangssperre
nur der weg zur arbeit oder zum arzt ist
dann erlaubt schulen und kitas bleiben
geschlossen
die zahlen so rasant steigen dann muss
man ja irgendwas radikales machen
also es ist nicht schön bitter aber ich
glaube notwendig hast du noch was kluges
dazu zu sagen
der grund für das harte vorgehen die
ausbreitung der britischen virus
mutation bei 117 fast jeder der sich
hier neu infiziert trägt die mutante in
sich und es gibt deutlich mehr corona
tote wir haben in diesen ersten
anderthalb monaten dieses jahres schon
mehr verstorbene als im gesamten letzten
jahren
das sind natürlich in gewisser weise
tatsache mit denen wir umgehen müssen
auch den immer zieht konsequenzen und
macht 13 grenzübergänge zu deutschland
dicht im hotspot flensburg gelten
ausgangssperre und co erst mal für eine
woche mit der option verlängerung
wie genau entwickelt sich die korona
lage immer auf dem neuesten nachrichten
stand sind sie mit unserem corona blog
online und in der zdf- heute- app
weitere wichtige themen heute gleich
zweimal stand der prominenteste kreml
gegner heute vor gericht und zweimal
hieß es keine gnade für alexej nawalny
der 44-jährige muss in ein straflager
im berufungsverfahren wurde lediglich
das strafmaß um sechs wochen auf
zweieinhalb jahre verkürzt
navalny soll gegen bewährungsauflagen
verstoßen haben während er sich in
berlin von einem giftanschlag erholte im
zweiten verfahren gab es eine geldstrafe
wegen angeblicher beleidigung eines
weltkriegs veteranen aus moskau
berichtet christian sie in handschellen
wird russlands bekanntester
oppositioneller in den gerichtssaal
gebracht alexej nawalny kennt das
mittlerweile seit seiner rückkehr aus
deutschland im januar pendelt er
zwischen gefängniszelle und anklagebank
das gericht bestätigte heute wenig
überraschend die haftstrafe gegen
navalny zweieinhalb jahre straflager
nur wenige anhänger navalny es waren vor
das gerichtsgebäude gekommen
die macht hat angst vor einer möglichen
wende die ganze polizei die herumsteht
sie haben angst vor kundgebungen navalny
hat keine angst die wahrheit in unserem
land auszusprechen er ist ein held dass
er nach russland zurückgekehrt ist um
gegen die ungerechtigkeit zu kämpfen
nur zwei stunden nach dem urteil stand
navalny schon wieder vor gericht
gleicher glaskasten anderer prozess
diesmal ging es um beleidigung eines
weltkriegs veteranen
hier wurde nach wahlen jedoch zu einer
geldstrafe in höhe von umgerechnet rund
9500 euro verurteilt alle appelle auch
aus europa waren die freizulassen hatte
der kreml als einmischung in die inneren
angelegenheiten russlands bezeichnet
navalny im gefängnis sitzt oder nicht
spielt keine rolle
im gefängnis ist er ein symbol eine
ikone des protests die führungsfigur für
die protestierenden und die russische
führung hat ihn dazu gemacht
navalny bezeichnete das verfahren erneut
als absurd
er habe nicht bereut nach russland
zurückgekehrt zu sein sagt navalny heute
und er will weiter kämpfen das thema
meinungsfreiheit treibt seit tagen
menschen in spanien auf die straßen
auslöser ist er der rapper pablo s l der
die monarchie beleidigt haben soll und
dafür ins gefängnis muss kein einzelfall
immer wieder werden journalisten
künstler privatleute verurteilt
grundlage sind zwei gesetzte von 2015
die in spanien von vielen als maulkorb
gesetze bezeichnet werden
die demonstranten auf der straße sehen
ihre meinungsfreiheit bedroht christel
hass berichtet dichter stinkt der qualm
steigt auf in den straßen von barcelona
die vierte nacht in folge brennen
mülltonnen fliegen steine posieren
demonstranten mit eindeutigen gesten vor
dem chaos
gewaltsames ende einer demonstration die
wie alle vorher nicht genehmigt war und
die eigentlich mehr meinungsfreiheit
verlangte ich bin hier weil ich diesen
polizeistaat ablehne und weil unsere
freiheiten eingeschränkt sind
[Musik]
er ist der auslöser pablo sl ein rapper
seine texte und tweets sind radikal in
ihnen nennt er den könig einen tyrannen
und wünscht manchen politikern eine
kugel in den kopf
er wurde wegen gewaltverherrlichung und
majestätsbeleidigung zu neun monaten
haft verurteilt
eine harte strafe ermöglicht durch
scharfe gesetze die seit jahren
umstritten sind
der straftatbestand besteht so nicht in
keinem anderen europäischen land sollte
ersatzlos gestrichen werden weil die
verhaltensweisen die darin inbegriffen
sind sind schon durch andere straftaten
gedeckt einsichtig zeigte sich
ministerpräsident sanchez es gebe
defizite die behoben werden müssten
manila die hausaufgabe für spaniens
demokratie ist es die meinungsfreiheit
zu starten
es ist der versuch die gemüter zu
beruhigen
heute abend aber soll erst mal wieder
protestiert werden auch in myanmar gehen
die proteste weiter unter anderen
vorzeichen bei demonstrationen gegen den
militärputsch sind mittlerweile offenbar
wieder menschen getötet worden
nach berichten lokaler medien kamen zwei
männer ums leben als die polizei auf
teilnehmer einer kundgebung schoss
zahlreiche weitere menschen wurden
verletzt
gestern erlag eine junge frau ihren
verletzungen eine symbolfigur der
proteste hier war in den kopf geschossen
worden
[Musik]
es brodelt im atomstreit mit iran und
doch gibt es jetzt etwas hoffnung für
die diplomatie den us präsident joe
biden sieht offenbar noch chancen für
das atom abkommen dass iran vom bau
atomarer waffen abhalten soll
kurzer rückblick jetzt beiden vorgänger
donald trump will das abkommen für
unzureichend die usa stiegen aus und
verhängten harte wirtschaftssanktionen
der iran seinerseits verletzte die
auflagen reichert wieder stärker uran an
und behindert die kontrolleure der
internationalen atomenergiebehörde jörg
brase sie wollen wieder miteinander
reden die usa und iran doch zu welchen
bedingungen us präsident biden erklärte
gestern auf der münchner
sicherheitskonferenz
es solle nicht nur um das atom abkommen
gehen wir müssen auch die idee
stabilisieren den aktivitäten irans im
mittleren osten ansprechen und wir
werden dabei eng mit unseren
europäischen den anderen partnern
kooperieren
davon aber wollte er aber nichts wissen
zum gesprächsangebot der amerikaner von
präsident johann ii heute kein wort
offiziell heißt es nach wie vor dass
erst die sanktionen aufgehoben werden
müssen die bezeichnete irans führung
immer wieder als terrorakt gegen das
iranische volk
wir stehen unter sanktionen und müssen
gegen das corona virus kämpfen wegen der
sanktionen hatten wir große probleme
impfstoff zu besorgen und zu bezahlen
die menschen auf teherans straßen
interessiert das geschacher um das atom
abkommen wenig seit jahren wird die lage
immer schlechter
sie leiden unter hohen preisen und hoher
arbeitslosigkeit viele sind mit ihrer
geduld am ende
atomenergie nutzt uns gar nichts die
leute haben hunger und sind völlig
durcheinander atomenergie mag uns in der
zukunft helfen aber priorität hat jetzt
unser lebensunterhalt man sei
zuversichtlich die politischen probleme
mit den usa bald lösen zu können erklärt
heute irans regierungssprecher noch aber
ist das vor allem ein frommer wunsch und
zurück zu uns nach deutschland wenige
tage nach der explosion von briefbomben
bei lebensmittelfirmen hat die polizei
einen verdächtigen festgenommen
es handelt sich um einen rentner aus dem
raum ulm er sitzt in untersuchungshaft
und schweigt bisher zu den vorwürfen
eine briefbombe war am mittwoch in der
lidl zentrale in neckarsulm explodiert
und hatte drei menschen verletzt
einen tag vorher hatte es bereits eine
explosion bei dem
lebensmittelproduzenten wild dem
hersteller von capri sun gegeben und
jetzt zu einem kapitel ganz früher
nachkriegsgeschichte einem tragischen
kapitel
es ereignete sich heute vor genau 75
jahren in bergkamen in der nähe von
dortmund auf zeche grimberg tief unter
tage eine explosion 405 bergleute wurden
getötet die meisten von ihnen wurden nie
geborgen
heute gedenken sie dort der opfer des
schwersten grubenunglücks in der
deutschen geschichte
andrea bögge
[Musik]
am ehrenmal für die opfer er klingt das
steigerlied bis heute trauert bergkamen
um die bergleute die auf der
schachtanlage grimberg vor 75 jahren
verunglückten 405 kumpels verloren
damals ihr leben und die tragik kann man
glaube ich dadurch ermessen dass viele
überhaupt nicht gerettet werden konnten
und lebendig begraben wurden
einer der verunglückten bergmänner paul
neugebauer seien heute 84 jähriger sohn
ernst ist damals neun jahre alt und mit
dem fahrrad unterwegs und dann gab es
einen riesenknall und ich habe damals
immer gesagt es waren gewitter hat sich
dann nach hause kam
da sagte ich meine mutter das ist ein
unglück gegeben habe dass also eine
schwere explosion geschehen soll
die gasexplosion zerstört große teile
der zechen anlage über und unter tage in
der grube brechen gewaltige brände aus
die nur unzureichend ausgerüstete
grubenwehr versucht tage lang
verzweifelt überlebende zu retten
zur schachtanlage und stand draußen
viele menschen die dann also an der
schifflände standen und warteten bis mal
jemand überhaupt gerettet wurde und
rauskam
sechs tage später wird beschlossen die
grube zu zubetonieren um das feuer zu
stoppen hunderte bergleute viele von
ihnen noch lebend bleiben für immer
unten auch ernst neugebauers vater paul
einziger trost ausgelöst durch das
unglück wird die sicherheit im deutschen
steinkohlebergbau danach deutlich
verbessert sowas macht man strich so ist
das in dieser sendung manchmal kommt zu
einem ganz anderen thema vor einer woche
waren auch schneeschippen und eis
kratzen und jetzt werden die ersten
griffen entstaubt und beete umgegraben
der frühling ist da zumindest bei den
temperaturen bis zu 20 grad in der sonne
an diesem wochenende besonders am rhein
ist es sehr mild ariane gödel
die sonne ist da und schon die die welt
ganz anders aus
die hähne werden munter
die hennen legen wieder mehr eier und
diese will ihre sogar ausbrüten
frühlingserwachen auch bei den bienen
sie hält nicht mehr in ihrem stock beim
imker weiß dass es frühling gekommen ist
ohne im kalender zu gucken
es reicht wenn ich auf meine bienen
fliegen
die strecken schon blütenpollen raus aus
der wohnung rein ins licht an die sonne
das haben heute auch die menschen
genossen nicht nur in bonn am rhein
es ist schon schön wenn man immer drin
ist und home office mobile working und
da mal wieder raus zu können das ist
schon toll also meine laune ist
eigentlich immer gut ich lasse mir auch
von carola nicht die laune verderben
aber natürlich so neu ist das ist schon
was tolles das erste in bonn 14 grad im
breisgau in freiburg sogar 17 grad heute
mittag auch hier findet das leben
draußen statt natürlich mit abstand es
soll schön dass man einfach wieder zeit
draußen verbringen kann auch mal ein
bierchen trinken kaffee trinken
das tut einfach als hauptstück wilden
von auch dass wir hier keine masken
pflicht mehr in der innenstadt haben
weil die inzidenz war untergegangen sind
das macht einfach wir haben 40 eben frei
ob in freiburg oder in bonn viele ort
soll es zumindest in den nächsten tagen
frühlingshaft bleiben wahnsinn
immer wieder war so was das wetter
ausmacht oder christin leider noch mal
ab in den winter nämlich leider ist toll
freude und enttäuschung bei den
deutschen staffeln am vorletzten tag der
weltmeisterschaften in pokljuka
slowenien
während die männer durch die schwäche
von erik lesser platz 7 hinnehmen müssen
wir jubeln die frauen ihre
silbermedaille endlich so sagte
franziska preuß haben auch wir einen
grund zu feiern das rennen geprägt von
auf und absolut dank der aufholjagd von
denise herrmann schnuppert das deutsche
quartett nach zwischenzeitlichem
rückstand wieder an einer medaille
schlussläuferin polster nervenstark
sowohl liegend als auch stehend mit fünf
treffer gold vergeben an norwegen aber
der kampf um silber entfacht zwischen
der ukraine und deutschland
preuß mit einer beeindruckenden
schlussrunde gold geht an norwegen
bronze für die ukraine
bei den männern erwischt läufer ihre
gläser einen rabenschwarzen tag der
körper streikt beim ersten wechsel liegt
deutschland aussichtslos zurück auf rang
20 für die anderen drei heißt es
schadensbegrenzung am ende platz sieben
neuer weltmeister norwegen dahinter
schweden und dritter die staffel aus
russland zum 22 spieltag der
fußball-bundesliga bei dem es auch um
das gedenken an die opfer des anschlags
von hornau geht hier die profis von
eintracht frankfurt mit besonderen
trikots als symbol der anteilnahme vor
dem anpfiff des heimspiels gegen den fc
bayern münchen und am ende gewinnen die
gastgeber die spitzenpartie gegen die
personell geschwächten bayern mit 2 zu 1
ebenso mainz überraschend bei gladbach
freiburg union und köln stuttgart enden
jeweils null zu eins alles zum revier
derby schalke dortmund ausführlich im
sportstudio gestern wieder fällt
wolfsburg 0 zu 3 morgen noch drei spiele
bei denen leipzig mit einem sieg bis auf
zwei punkte an tabellenführer münchen
heranrücken kann dahinter tauschen
wolfsburg und frankfurt die plätze union
nun vor gladbach und freiburg in der
unteren hälfte vorläufig keine
veränderungen am ende holt mainz weiter
auf wobei die abstiegskandidaten ringsum
alle noch spielen müssen
gesprächsbedarf bei den bayern passen
dazu der chef karl heinz rummenigge
nachher im aktuellen sportstudio live
von 23 uhr an bei jochen breyer japans
tennis star naomi osaka hat zum zweiten
mal nach 2009 10 die autorin open in
melbourne gewonnen in zwei sätzen gegen
denner vorbei die usa sie kennt das
inzwischen denn bereits zum vierten mal
bei einem grand-slam-turnier
heldt nahm user den siegerpokal
gegen die überraschungs finalistin
jennifer grey die aus den usa lässt die
23 jahre alte japanerin in zwei glatten
sätzen keine zweifel daran wer im
damen-tennis derzeit die nummer eins ist
mit diesem hohen anspruch liegt sie auf
einer linie mit vielen tennis fans und
experten die überzeugt davon sind
vergleichbare siegerposen von osaka auch
in zukunft noch öfter zu sehen und
morgen djokovic oder medwedew bei den
männern christin vielen dank ein
bisschen wetter hatten wir schon in der
sendung jetzt kommt noch die frage 20
grad im februar wie ungewöhnlich ist
dass und die antwort kommt dann auch
gleich von osten telli um 22 uhr 45
übernimmt der kollege claus kleber die
nachrichtenlage im heute-journal von uns
allen im team 19 danke fürs zuschauen
und einen sehr angenehmen samstagabend
tschüss
[Musik]
ein show guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter wie ungewöhnlich
20 grad im februar sind sind wir hier in
unserer statistik von 1961 bis 1980
waren es dreimal ähnlich von 1981 bis
2000 und ab 2001 also den vergangenen 20
jahren kam es dann gehäuft vor also acht
mal und jetzt stehen wieder 20 grad an
schauen wir uns mal die großwetterlage
an und da sehen sie die warme luft die
aus dem südwesten kommt hier herrschen
who ein starkes hoch und die tiefste
kommen dagegen nicht an und bringt eben
die wärme mit
und so sieht es in der nacht aus es
bildet sich nebel im süden vor allem in
gewässernähe hier minus drei bis plus
ein grad nach norden etwas milder bei 0
bis 9 grad
und morgen im tagesverlauf löst sich der
nebel teilweise auf teilweise bleibt er
aber auch und dann ist es eben trüb
sonst ist aber sehr viel sonnenschein
dabei bei höchsten temperaturen von zehn
grad im südosten deutschlands und bis zu
20 grad im westen sehen aber häufig wird
die 15 grad marke überschritten
die kommenden tage viel sonnenschein
nach nebelauflösung und temperaturen ab
dienstag wieder um die 20 grad marke
ein schöner abend